[Musique]
votre voyage s'est fracassé contre la
pandémie vous attendez toujours que le
fonds d'indemnisation des clients des
agents voyage viennent nous secourir
essayé de tenir le coup vous devrez
attendre encore un peu
les agences de voyages qui ont fait
affaire avec les transporteurs canadiens
ont remboursé la grande majorité de
leurs clients mais si votre agence a
fait affaire avec un transporteur
étranger un hôtelier champêtre un
croisiériste réticents ou encore si
votre agence a fermé ses portes ou
refusent de vous rembourser vous fait
sans doute partie de ceux qui attendent
toujours une bouée et c'est là que le
ficav va vous aider le ficav c'est le
dernier payeur et il veut s'assurer de
ne pas payer en double
chaque réclamation est donc examiner une
à une
4000 demandes ont été annulées parce que
les voyageurs avaient déjà été
remboursés mais il en reste encore plus
de 30000 à analyser c'est donc une
opération titanesque
passer le mot